welcome to this video chesa Sookie
chesus p91 hmm ok don't think i played
this guy Carlos AVR ok this is his
Uruguay or something yep I got that one
right so we got a 45 white to choose ok
so we gotta ruin Lopez ok it's going for
this line yeah I like b5 and b6 cm to
have Bishop d7 ready whenever a four
hits White has to care about 95 here
though he cannot just give away his
Bishop so he normally goes a483 are one
of those songs ok it's bishop e6 a move
here let's try this out I really do know
this line too well which is some job I
have to admit which is a mistake on my
part I should know it better this d3 is
coming into its becoming a very
fashionable continuation in term not
having something great there is some I
mean great there's nothing great but
yeah knowing nothing in much detail as a
bit of a it's bad so what to do here but
sure that I want to play d 5 in this
position
you might play deform okay that's not
the end of the world I can take and play
c5 trying to reroute the night 27 and
then possibly play c5 the knight on c6
as usual doesn't doesn't do much and so
I'm going to reposition it not sure what
is doing on f7 I have to admit that
that's interesting I thought if I've
might be okay if we take c5 I mean I
have d3 something that I can play
against okay so i can take now play for
yeah why not so what is he doing there d
4 s.s idea right is this is this a huge
problem not sure I can go D 5 D 5 and
possibly harm possibly deform yeah then
the Queen in this King diagonal here
that it's a bit of a bit of a nuisance
really ok that's a good let's remove
this ok so like d5 and t4 now right
let's do that
yeah my five porn is a bit weak so I'm
taking this space
don't understand yet what he's getting
at
okay I'm just going to trade those it's
not a problem anyway I to trade the
rooks the only scenario that is a bit
tricky here for me sometimes is a
situation where it's down to my nappies
end game where he potentially can go for
an f4 break but that's really far down
the road g3 weird okay get the King a
bit nearer here does he want to go jeet
493 thats it's a really weird idea don't
don't believe in that much so i'm going
to i really don't understand this so
going to g for what okay so there's some
way to continue i can go like this just
control g 5y doesn't have any particular
idea in this position at least i don't
see it how to play though here as black
can try to trade some things doesn't
help doesn't hurt maybe he's so allowing
a night xe4 tactic if he's not very
circumspect
and probably not i can go g5 maybe g5
looks bad for my bishop but it grabs
space it's not a bad bad way of playing
um okay i'm close to able to sacrifice
on your form but i need some more prep
for that so time morning so maybe maybe
let's try this Bishop g5 that's not
exceed form it's quite interesting and
up for Angie form I mean he really
didn't do anything in this game mostly
shuffled around but he did it in a quick
way this is said this is of course an
important important part and so let's
take this not trying to get to the pawn
you have to take it once more to to win
the pond
Quincy five or what exactly queen bee
age let's cover this night g6 then hmm
hmm Jack got 20 seconds left this is
this is a problem the position i'm not
sure about okay let's see if I can Queen
each one Queen B 5 is a draw now and
yeah that's another time is sizing
fender here position is nothing for what
I think with this open King and I don't
think he can can't win this check
it's really nothing going on check yeah
no I'm no I'm better probably winning
the pawn them but this is the this is
the town control he can do whatever he
wants because you will win on time check
check check
black4 fits on time what what was this
some kind of leg issue James I had some
lack thereof seven seconds and i forfeit
it on time yeah great yeah okay I mean I
would have lost on time very likely
anyway even without this technical
problem i'm not sure what this is
assists now a draw we know whatever yeah
i mean this is probably just winning rod
and Jack and I mean I my pawn is just
I'm just meeting him probably yeah I did
I think this was a game where white
never had anything I'm just just
shuffling around with no particular
purpose but he did it in a quick way
which is which is helpful yeah well here
this is just just about equal
disposition but I spent too much time
spend too much time on it I also
probably spent too much time trying to
think about possible ideas that he might
have but he just never did anything you
just shuffled around okay I could have
chicken only form yeah I actually wanted
to prepare that yeah i saw this idea but
i wanted to prepare that the other
computer actually gives me gives me i
have almost winning advantage here which
is quite amazing ok when his pieces look
entirely stupid him but still surprised
how good this is maybe this is what I
should have done but okay i'm hugh i
prepared that but now okay this kind of
thing I mean I I wanted to get something
active going because of the time and um
Jim yeah yeah I'm in trouble and I just
six was strong neither three was was a
bit strange this is now probably just
winning I don't know why have plus five
call
to the engine this is this is just bad
and the game continues and he I'm always
okay due to his bad King position but of
course he can play on time and did that
yeah I know I was just I was just
spending too much time thinking that he
might do something which which he never
did it's just um nothing happening i
should have chicken he fall it would
have been much better getting something
concrete going that's with them maybe
allows me to play more moose yeah at the
end it was probably I mean this was a
bit unlucky that had this this weird
disconnection thing or whatever it was
um but six seconds it's very unlikely
that he runs into a mate I mean black is
winning now but it's it's just six
seconds so am I would have lost some
time very likely anyway okay thanks for
watching